[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique elle a une ce soir ce coup
monter des mercenaires russes de Wagner
au Mali l'armée française les accusent
vidéo à l'appui d'avoir installé un
charnier à Gossi en faisant croire que
c'était l'oeuvre de la France
explication à suivre dès le début de ce
journal
la Tunisie et la nouvelle dérive
autoritaire de son président après
s'être arrosée les pleins pouvoirs et
suspendus le Parlement l'année dernière
il vient de nommer le chef de l'Autorité
électorale celui-là même chargé de
contrôler les élections vous entendrez
celui qui a été remplacé et qui dénonce
une dictature
et ce soir nous recevons une chanteuse
exceptionnelle à la voix unique à Laura
envoûtante une icône féministe engagée
auprès des femmes et des enfants un
modèle pour le continent africain la
diva malienne Oumou Sangare et notre
invité et elle vient nous présenter son
tout nouvel album timbuku à la fois
intime et universel avec un mélange de
blues américain ou est né cet album elle
nous en parlera
un coup monté pour lamée française cela
fait aucun doute elle accuse le groupe
russe Wagner d'être à l'origine d'une
opération de désinformation au Mali le
groupe de paramilitaires accusé l'armée
française d'avoir laissé un charnier
après l'évacuation du camp de Gossip et
fait exceptionnel la grande muette a
publié des vidéos prouvant le contraire
les explications de Bilal taramé
ce serait la preuve d'une mise en scène
cette vidéo fait partie d'une série
d'images fournies par l'armée française
et tournée par un avion ou un drone elle
montre des hommes que la France désigne
comme étant des membres du groupe Wagner
en train d'ensevelir des corps dans le
sable à 3 km et demi du camp de Gossi au
Mali
ce mardi 19 avril les soldats français
rétrosèdent ce camp aux forces armées
maliennes dans son communiqué daté du
jour même l'état-major insiste sur un
transfert dans la transparence la plus
totale dans un contexte où la force
barkhane fait face à des attaques
informationsnels visant tant entacher
son action et sa crédibilité
dès le lendemain un tweet émis par un
faux compte dénonce un crime contre le
peuple malien par les Français et évoque
des images de cadavragosi le
surlendemain le même compte diffuse
cette vidéo elle montre des corps
enfouis dans le sable présenté commenter
et agressif voici la vidéo en plein
écran et voici les images du même moment
tourné par l'armée française elle montre
des hommes en uniforme en train de
filmer ses corps car l'armée française a
fait exprès de filmer le camp de Gossip
après son départ on y voit dès le
lendemain mercredi 20 un aller-retour de
véhicules de fabrication chinoise
utilisée par l'armée malienne et les
mercenaires de Wagner puis des photos de
nuit avec les baraquements des soldats
maliens et des mercenaires russes et
enfin le 21 au matin cette vidéo d'homme
qui enterre des cadavres avant de les
filmer quelques heures avant la
diffusion du second tweet ce qui est
intéressant dans tout ça c'est qu'on a
vu la construction d'une des armes des
informations par un faux compte et pour
la première fois l'armée française a
décidé de prendre les devants et d'en
parler déjà puis de décider de diffuser
quelques images parce qu'ils ont en tête
le précédent du convoi de Berkane qui a
été raté par deux fois au Burkina Faso
puis au au Niger à cause d'une des
informations dès qu'on voit de barkhane
pria parti au Sahel comme ici au Niger
en novembre dernier des rumeurs
circulaient sur les réseaux sociaux
elles affirmaient que les soldats du
convoi transporter des armes destinées
au djihadiste
on passe à la Tunisie ou le président a
fait un pas de plus vers l'accaparement
des pouvoirs après s'être arrangé les
pleins pouvoirs le 25 juillet dernier
suspendu le Parlement voilà qu'une nomme
le chef de l'Autorité électorale ceci à
quelques mois d'un référendum et des
législatives écoutez celui qui occupait
justement ce poste jusqu'à lors Nabil
bafoune
dictature Kenneth et qui s'agrandit au
fil des jours et c'est à partir du 25
juillet que ça commençait notre instance
électorale est a perdu la qualité
d'indépendance puisque son prochain
conseil ainsi que son prochain président
seront désignés et nommés uniquement par
le Président de la République
sincèrement et apparemment les prochains
échéances électorales seront organisées
et supervisé par le palais de Carthage
le fait de nommer et désigner toute
l'équipe de cette façon là on est hors
la loi
l'autre actualité en Tunisie concerne le
naufrage du mystérieux zélo le navire
qui transportait normalement 750 tonnes
de gasoil or le ministère de
l'Environnement a déclaré après pompage
que ces cuves étaient remplies d'eau il
n'y avait pas de pétrole les
explications de notre correspondante il
y a Blaise
les zones d'ombres s'accumulent autour
d'une naufrage du navire xéno qui avait
coulé au large de Gabès le 16 avril
depuis une semaine les équipes
tunisiennes assistaient aussi de
l'Italie c'était mobilisé pour extraire
les supposés 750 tonnes de gazole que
transporter le navire et qui menaçait la
zone d'une marée noire en cas de fuite
aujourd'hui ce vendredi les autorités
tunisiennes notamment la Marine
nationale et le mystère de
l'environnement ont déclaré qu'il
n'avaient pas trouvé de gazole dans les
citerne au moment de l'extraction les
citernes seraient remplies d'eau de mer
selon les déclarations de la Marine
nationale c'est un mystère de plus
autour des circonstances aussi du
naufrage du navire xello avec beaucoup
de contradictions puisque les membres de
l'équipage auraient également menti sur
la trajectoire du navire qui était
supposée être partie du port de Damiette
en Égypte pour s'orienter vers Malte les
autorités égyptiennes ont démenti que le
navire xello se répartit d'Egypte et
puis il y a eu aussi des zones d'ombre
sur un l'absence d'un document un
document très important le connaissement
qui normalement répertorie toutes les
cargaisons du navire qui a
mystérieusement disparu et le mystère de
l'environnement avait en effet
questionné aussi cette disparition
aujourd'hui donc plus de risques de
marinois selon le mystère de
l'environnement qui a annoncé la
suspension des opérations de pompage
mais l'enquête judiciaire continue les
membres de l'équipage ont été interdits
de voyage par le parquet de Gabès
l'absence ou le manque de carburant est
aussi remarqué au Burundi là-bas
plusieurs activités qui faisaient vivre
beaucoup de familles sont à présent
paralysés c'est le cas de la pêche sur
le lac tanganica les bateaux sont à
l'arrêt conséquence des étals sont vides
écoutez ces quelques réactions tournées
à roue mungo à quelques 70 km au sud de
bois
les pêcheurs sont les premiers à être
affectés car c'est le produit qu'on
utilise tous les jours ces bateaux que
vous voyez ne peuvent pas bouger d'ici
sans carburant au début de cette pénurie
nous avons essayé de nous débrouiller
mais à un certain moment ce n'était plus
possible et nous avons arrêté la pêche
or on vivait de ce métier nos familles
vivaient de ça
on passe à la culture et nous recevons
ce soir une femme une voix une aura une
diva qui depuis plus de 30 ans a bâti
une carrière exceptionnelle partant des
quartiers pauvres de Bamako aux Orres
hollywoodiens sans sacrifier ni sa
culture ni ses engagements merci Oumou
Sangare d'être notre invité du journal
de l'Afrique sur France 24 alors vous
êtes venus nous présenter ce nouvel
album Timbuktu qui résonne
malheureusement avec l'actualité au Mali
et je vous demandais justement ce que
vous aviez envie de dire et quel message
vous avez envie de faire passer
vous savez le message que j'ai à passer
c'est toujours le même message le
message de paix
nous les hommes de culture notre rôle
c'est vraiment d'apaiser le cœur
en cas de tension d'apaiser les cœurs le
maximum d'essai de faire revenir la paix
dans le cœur de tout le monde
et quand pourquoi Tombouctou parce que
ces choix voilà Tombouctou c'est une
ville très importante pour moi c'est une
ville
une ville sacrée pour pour toute
l'humanité et
aussi
mais je suis grand-mère mes trois
princesses leurs origines elles sont de
Tombouctou parce que mon fils l'origine
est Tombouctou à marié une arabe
tombouctoune pour vous dire comment le
métissage entre le Nord et le Sud est
fort au Mali et alors dans dans cet
album d'ailleurs dans le morceau qui
éponyme qui donne son titre à l'album de
tout vous dites malien réveillons-nous
de ce grand sommeil et gardons à
l'esprit combien nous fume grand et
soyez sûr que nous pouvons le rester
c'est vrai absolument magnifique mais
alors justement parlons de musique et de
cet album que vous avez fait vous
pendant le confinement vous métier on va
dire entre guillemets coincé à Baltimore
en fait je ne suis pas parti en
confinement je suis après mon festival
de fiwa je suis parce que si je viens en
France France c'est la maison c'est la
famille il y a beaucoup de fans beaucoup
de de de famille je n'aurais pas les la
le repos que je veux donc après le fiwa
qui qui accueille plus de 300000
personnes à 120 km
à 240 km de Bamako donc c'était c'est
pas facile je suis après les filles
ouais je suis allée aux États-Unis en
voulant faire deux semaines de repos
deux semaines les les frontières sont
fermés je suis mais je me retrouve
coincé j'ai dit ok c'est bien parce
qu'après 30 ans quand même je suis
fatigué je vais me reposer pour moi
c'est quelque chose de d'une semaine
deux semaines et c'est parti 3 mois je
me suis tapé trois mois à New York mon
Dieu Oumou Sangare 3 mois sans rien
faire
à mort donc je me suis je me suis
commencé à dire la Vie niortaise j'adore
New York mais vivre à New York c'est il
faut le faire oui c'est compliqué voilà
donc j'ai commencé à sortir dehors un
peu de Niort pour aller voir un peu à
côté si je peux trouver une petite
appartement pour m'éloigner un peu de
New York la nuit pour pour m'inspirer
parce que je m'ennuyais le travail me
manquait j'étais donc du coup je suis
allée à Baltimore et j'ai trouvé ce que
je vais là-bas tout de suite j'ai fait
appel à un joueur de Bonnie pour qu'il
vienne chez moi
et voilà et c'est de là que l'album
tombouctou est né en pleine nostalgie
très loin de ma famille très loin de
de mon Afrique donc
un petit morceau de
Westmalle juste après votre région
d'origine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit ce mélange de sonorité cet album
vraiment est absolument magnifique je le
recommande il y a toutes les sonorités
il y a absolument des textes absolument
engagés mais aussi léger voilà qui parle
de vous vous y parlez beaucoup de vous
dans cet album oui je parle beaucoup de
moi parce que j'étais seul loin de la
famille j'avais la nostalgie de
l'Afrique de mon pays le Mali voilà mais
aussi j'ai profité pour que la lutte
continue j'ai parlé beaucoup de la femme
de la situation de la femme les enfants
dominent c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'associations qui font beaucoup de
choses mais jusqu'à présent les enfants
sont toujours dans la rue et au bord de
mosquée vous vous êtes
africaine vous connaissez les enfants
sont livrés à eux-mêmes là j'interpelle
vraiment les dirigeants complètement de
de faire quelque chose parce que c'est
ses enfants là c'est l'avenir de demain
si on les livre à eux vraiment l'Afrique
n'aura pas d'avenir en laissant les
enfants comme ça dans la rue donc
j'interpelle tous les dirigeants
africains vraiment de faire face à ces
fleueux seront enfants dans la rue vous
voyez absolument zéro à fond dans la rue
qui est absolument un fléau vous êtes
une icône féministe on le sait très
engagé
c'était notre plaisir de vous recevoir
ici dans le jeu
vraiment c'était formidable on va
évidemment alors moi j'avais un petit
rêve je me disais peut-être que vous
pourriez me chanter je sais pas avec
plaisir
on va pas vous donner notre plaisir avec
plaisir alors je vous souhaite on vous
écoute
[Musique]
merci merci infiniment Oumou Sangare qui
est venu nous présenter Timbuktu c'était
un bonheur merci restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]
tu es tombé
un amour comme le nôtre
il n'en existe pas de
ce n'est pas celui des autres voilà
c'est quelque chose de mieux
sans me parler
je t'aime ce que tu veux me dire
[Musique]
pour se protéger il y a des gestes qui
comptent la protection apportée par le
vaccin contre le covid-19 diminue après
un certain temps une deuxième dose de
rappel est donc recommandée des 60 ans